so walk me through the actual business i
get the
i concept we've been going concept and
wide and we're now
sort of getting in in this discussion in
our third segment here
um how do you price it yeah price
so it's a sas business 100 of the
revenues are sas reoccurring
um we're unique for a sas business in
that
um individuals own their data and what
that enables is part of our vision for
lifelong learning
so even though it's an enterprise sas
business model
when you leave you get to take your
profile and your data
with you to your next employer
and what that's enabled and uh and we'll
come back to the economics on it but
what that enables is we've
i've been very disciplined and all of
our clients we've kept them
um using the same standard of language
for skills and skill measurement so what
that means is for the first time in the
world if you are
at um if you're at uh hsbc or if you're
at citibank or if you're at bank of
america
and you leave and you go to a visa or a
mastercard or you go to usaa
you go to a prudential or you know being
a level four
in international tax now means the same
thing
at all of those institutions and people
get to take their data and their profile
and essentially their their skills
record their skill profile
with them uh and anywhere that's using
degreed
it it holds universal meaning and
universal context
and what's particularly brilliant about
that you gave the
um perspective of the individual and how
amazing that is hey i'm going to this
new company
i send them my link on degreed
if they do not have degree they say
what's degreed
and then it is making your product viral
so
now they say oh maybe we should have
degreed and when they take that job
there
i'm assuming they add that they now work
at this new company
and now your sales department in the sas
department now knows who to call
to infect the new company with degree
correct just like salesforce sort of
infected every company as
they went along but this is even more
viral if if you think about you know
when we need to work with people you
know where they've worked matters at
their experience
you know who they are who they know and
what they know or what their skills are
all of those things do matter
and the resume in linkedin has
historically really been about
who do you know yep and what your
experiences are
yep and you know really degreed by going
in and
serving enterprise and being the the
giving an organization transparency
into what skills everyone inside their
organization has
has now become the system of record for
some of the world's largest
organizations we're being used
we're coming up on half of the fortune
200 we're we're somewhere between
a third and half of uh the world's
largest organizations
use degree to enterprise wide top to
bottom top of the organization all the
way down
and so for the first time ever
organizations are able to ask and answer
the question
you know what skills do we have what
skills do we need
and how do we you know get to where we
need to go
and as simple as that sounds ceos
couldn't do that you know two three four
years ago
and it is a real benefit when
a young person or even an older person
or particularly young people come to an
organization
and you say to them hey we're going to
give you five thousand dollars towards
like night school i remember that was
like a big thing when we were coming up
in the in the 90s like
will they pay for my masters or
continuing education they would you know
different places had different stipends
thousand dollars
unlimited whatever in your case this is
a real benefit because
i mean a benefit in terms of like
healthcare dental education is
continuing education is is a benefit
it should be considered as such by the
employee correct
yeah and one of the ways we've really
reoriented the conversation
is that corporate training was
historically all about governance and
compliance and so it never
felt like you were investing in me the
person it always felt like you were
asking me to go learn something to to
cover your ass
and you know we've we've switched that
paradigm
this is now lifelong i get to take this
record with me
and i get to see all the resources that
the company is making available to me
and we've really reoriented it around
your development
as an employee rather than the companies
sort of uh requisite
sort of compliance and governance and
requisite needs so it's really
employee driven got it how do you charge
you're charged by course by employees of
five dollars a month per active user
like
sort of like the slack model where you
only charge for active people because i
can see that being a roadblock you go
into an organization with 10 000 people
only 100 people use the product people
don't want to pay 60 a year for ten
thousand would pay six dollars a year
for those
100 people who used it how do you charge
um
we charge per employee per year and we
charge for everyone in the organization
how much yeah tens tens of dollars per
person per year
okay so i i guess sixty dollars a person
a year um does that mean they
if they have to use it if they don't use
it do you still have to pay or is it
only proactive user
it's for all all employees okay our
clients pay for everyone to use it
whether or not they ever log in we have
very high degrees of
activation and engagement and that's uh
you know some of our clients
were seeing you know this this whole
refocusing on the employee changes
everything some of our
um clients they were seeing around
non-compliance learning
they were seeing less than 10 percent of
the organization
engage annually and now a majority of
our clients will see
more than half of the organization
engage in non-compliance learning
monthly and if you do that math i mean
that's orders of
magnitude the hr department must be
we've been able to drive in terms of
engagement
the hr and the learning whatever the
development
groups must be over the moon with this
what are the most popular
courses and who creates the courses
yes so we bring the ecosystem together
articles videos books podcast courses
moocs e-learning
conferences events we are not the
training provider and we do not develop
the content
we are just bringing it all together so
that it is
organized in one place you can search by
topic you can go for javascript
and see what courses your organization
has that they've developed you can see
all of the vendors a plural site a
linkedin learning a udemy
you can see all of the courses that
they've purchased and made available to
you
as well as you can just see every course
on javascript out there
full stop um and see if there's one
that is outside of your company's um
vendors that you would prefer to take
and so we just bring it all together in
one place
so the if the ceo comes in one day
and she says you know what everybody in
this goddamn organization needs to read
uh you know good to great or uh crossing
the chasm whatever it is or creativity
inc
even better creativity they could say
listen there's a master class on
creativity inc and there's a book for
creativity inc
i want to see exactly how many team
members i can get to read this because i
think creativity inc is essential and oh
there's a podcast where jcal
on this weekend startups did too uh
episode yeah i'm talking about myself in
the third person
um it's a two-parter she could then just
say to the organization i think this is
important that people
watch these podcasts read the book do
the master class and
you could then check off hey they
understand creativity
uh in the organization that is true and
i'll tell you further
is just creating that transparency being
able to see inside an organization what
your
ceo is learning is really powerful
and you know they may or may not ever
choose to go and tweet i just finished
this book and i really enjoyed it
with degreed inside the organization i'm
able to follow leaders i'm able to
follow my my mentors my manager
i'm able to see what they're learning
people are able to see what i'm learning
and just creating that transparency is
really powerful yeah a ceo reads an
article
and logs it on to greed and all of a
sudden you know
everyone inside the organization will
will have read it a week later